you
we are ready to get kicked off this is
the pollak tournament at the start at
least a small group of 30 but if you had
a look at that front page it is indeed a
strong group and a beefy one we have
here in I am penguin GM I am penguin
will say Larry let's go with Bishop f4
and maybe we'll play for c5 why not okay
let's just challenge the piece that's in
my position for starters I'm really
going to go for g5 let's find out this
is a hole in blacks position they could
look to challenger right away
um with Bishop to f6
on that I think I'll just take tonight
on g5 I'm planning Knight takes Knight
and then Bishop to e5 I'm gonna try to
play it where I I'm trying to play
against their light square Bishop
we'll see
they're in the think tank but they don't
need much time very fast player not just
a strong blitz player but bullet as well
super quick I wouldn't mind seeing this
really weakens the kingside is there a
connection issue I hope not I Knight
takes pawn takes in v6 I'll just be
capturing I can't maintain c5 I don't
think although they'd have to watch out
with this move knight c6 could sting no
I think something's wrong with their
connection no they were just in a think
tank for a while I guess they're going
for this kind of pac-man idea I guess
huh can I not just take a time out
though right now and take the knight
although what's wrong with taking the
rook
you
let's just take the material I don't see
it I'm gonna have to show me I think
pawn takes pawn bishop h4 f g3 I'm up
the exchange am I not okay
it's pretty odd is castle but the
exchange
I may want to just take the night allow
Queen takes pawn hmm I don't have much
time though
let's just play Queen to e1 Bishop h4 I
have g3 they have the bishops that
counts for something I would like to get
this in but Queen take Z 3 yeah I feel
like I want to give the material back
still focus against this guy okay
knight on f3 a force this issue
you
to get rid of that light square bishop I
think
kicking it into a much higher gear that
night is a bit sidelined I just dropped
the night
ah
you
oh that was not good at all
yeah now here comes the pond or mate
ah man
I dropped my knight on h3 I think I had
the right idea I think it was okay to
try and give that material back hmm I
don't I'm not I'm still not buying that
that was some good sacrifice but
certainly got me thinking maybe
overthinking
okay let's get the f-pawn involved and
then Knight to f6 I feel like I could
get a little bit more away with this now
that they've played f3 you know this is
a pretty weakening move possibilities
for enough for fork I could try that
right now
who
well let's grab upon
no no no we're gonna do this I think he
would be tracked down pretty easily so
we're gonna grab some space already and
maybe I just want my night to be the one
to take here
yeah I'm on the Queen let's just scoop
him up this is an idea
no castling with this guy around let's
grab this pawn king site castle Queen
can't go too far what are with these
checks we had a similar check in the
last game it shouldn't be something that
you could really take advantage of I got
that covered though okay I could just
move my king that's what my instinct
tells me just to not even allow the
Queen get here yeah let's do that I have
enough material anyhow I am up a piece
my king I'll be fine over here now this
is a threat as well as this move I'm
getting at situ although the bishop is
still trained on this diagonal see what
they do also c4 grab some space now I
could just take let's hit the Queen
first improve the Knights position and
only then take here I have this as well
multiple forking ideas I'm on the Queen
width checks so they have to do
something about that
yeah we're gonna take now and probably
just develop Bishop d7 I like this move
because it stops Knight here and it
prepares to connect rooks after King c7
huh you're not taking g6 let's get to an
open file with tempo
yeah I guess well I guess I would
probably have something right what the
night takes G to I am a pop-out son of
material so let's just complete
development I got that square covered I
missed out and where's the mate could
probably do without the rook let's start
with this check we should be able to get
a smothered mate actually or made on d2
yeah I think we're gonna have a
smothered mate
they may just resign here but yeah
that's me the king went here I had this
idea rook takes and then Knight to d2
would have been a nice finish but either
way okay we got a W in there still a lot
of time 44 and change let's see what we
get so in that one
threw in a fork my opponent ignored it
throwing in a fork of their own
although all right
let's try Sicilian why nots sure let's
break up the pawn duo secure my queen on
c7 and what next let's go at the b6 fish
should be 7 this fishing pole idea is
not not only something I just try and
bullet ok well it appears that they
don't want to Castle kingside
they want to secure this I could get
this move in right now No
let's try for that is this too early for
me to be open opening up maybe but I'm
gonna test it
they don't have this reply I have enough
support for this my queen on the other
hand will probably need to find a new
home it's a bit concerning so if I was
playing as white I would probably
instinctually just take with the C pawn
first and then give it a think cuz this
is most likely desirable it's not like
you're helping out a bishop commode
along this diagonal after I recapture so
yeah that move coupled with rook c1 and
yeah I'm kind of already regretting my
decision some but let's just try
something active here it may be that I
drop some material b4 is a move once
castled I think if they do it now I
could take and there is no Knight
discovery however after castles maybe I
could take here and on b4 me they could
take the knight and then get out of this
file with some tempo against the knight
this is a vulnerable diagonal so I know
I'm exposing my queen but I am with the
position opening up their King may in
fact be the one more vulnerable
long-term
so they're going straight in for that I
didn't think they could do this alright
so let's see oh my goodness
I'm missing stuff Queen to a4 ah I
totally missed it
can I still do something here I have to
take the night first I believe let's
start with that and can I get away with
this move and then rip to c8 maybe if it
works out it's clearly it's clearly by
chance Queen c2 I can insist on trying
to get this guy back on takes I take
here what a sharp one yeah
Knight move cannot be made and the rook
cannot be defended
so a night move I'm taking here with
check Oh in the end they're gonna just
pile up even more huh I guess so
hmm yeah
okay noted can I take here is this gonna
change things
do I have to make a rip upon move here I
wonder if I have to try something like
that yeah I think I may need to try that
otherwise they're gonna have this
tripling up idea I may need to go with
Knight d7 oh wow so messy don't get here
Queen yikes how am i castling I'm not
mmm I'm in big trouble very big trouble
I gotta hide and there's barely anywhere
to hide down to 20 seconds that's all I
have yikes
I think I have to do this mm-hmm and
then here hello Polly I don't have much
time cutting a crossfire and just gonna
pile up
to cut off this really fast and back
rank you Mouse artists you let's just be
sneaky time burners
no mates
you
don't know what to say ugliness I have
to try to get one good game in because I
have yet to play one good game and this
is dating back to the bullet game or the
bullet tournament I played before this a
bullet tournament
Saima and now this one and it's just
ugly on top of ugly
oh alright let's let's try c4 I guess
man okay well got away with one there
clearly let's go with Knight f3 he's
going to take a hike he's going on a
journey and the destination is the hole
in blacks position d5 looks fancy I'm
there in time to not only defend but
control this pawn break next I'm going
to try for a 3 in b4
let's jump in right now maybe I should
have done that immediately and reply to
a five I have a fork idea that they are
ignoring missing so I have some material
now
and they takes rook on the cards I'm
without my LightSquared bishop
but that shouldn't be so much of a so
much of an issue my queen my pawn
structure can help repair that we may
see this soon I'll take
I'll take again in also weakened my deep
on but I just want to kind of make sure
he doesn't come to life and I just kind
of want to post up on e3 even if I lose
this pawn it may be okay with that
so let's point here and maybe we get
active with the Queen pressure on the
night he can't move just yet this may be
a threat because the rook is unprotected
so I guess lining up b5 let's just
squash that idea right away I'd like to
do without f5 I want to keep this as my
shelter like my King's home right here
so I'd like to have I still need to
create some kind of pawn exchange so my
Brooks can finally play maybe that could
come in the form of h5 this is still a
fine home for my king
it's the F pond when you move him it's
that's when it's getting a serious
that's when it's getting very weakening
so I could go straight in for this I
don't need rook h1 first this is the
heart if he makes a capture there's some
serious weaknesses currently these are
the two weaknesses a capture would have
two more holes
in blacks kingside the black king side
quadrant less than 50 minute advantage
queen can't go too far she has a
responsibility let's first take hey
let's get on the open file I'm prepared
to take him out
and now what let's just double up my
queen is in an excellent spot covering
my base points stopping all these pawns
from moving she kinda she controls this
whole Queen side so let's strengthen my
position and I probably could have done
one better here
let's go here with the Queen first
what I mean by one better I probably
should have gone to f4 stubble up
and
now I could do F form I feel a bit more
comfortable now weakening my King
position because I don't see and this I
could exchange Queens first and then
take so I'm up a full rook they have a
pond for it but that will not be enough
now it's a full ruck and now we're
mopping or mopping up everything
the pawns are dropping 10 seconds
there go all the pawns
and let's just get my king involved a
little bit
where is he going looking for stalemate
there we go back to tournament okay yeah
I have fallen for that same tactic
before soon the night jumps in there you
see you know at that a five move it does
one thing for sure it stops a White's
plan of B form on the other hand there
are some clear weaknesses connected with
that which and that game was highlighted
playing very fast this max max let's
voluntarily drop back let's go for now
c5 Knight c6
expecting night here linking computer
would do this just to open his eyes
prepare to damage my structure
interferes with what it is I want to do
yes I think I'll still do it though yeah
so I have
potential targets now in the C file I
feel a little bit more confident
allowing this structural defect now that
the Queen Knight has already committed
to d2 if it was on its home square this
would be concerning because c5 could be
struck at a little bit more a little
easier let's just say so I think I want
to maintain upon in one of the four
center squares in large part due to
boxing out this night he does a good job
of controlling this guy alright I'm
gonna go with Queen b6
I'm anticipating some pressure against
c5 I don't want to have to do this
because this night is just gonna love
the c-4 square
although you know what maybe this is an
idea with the bishop on f6 it would take
quite a bit of work though also I can't
do this because that would kill my king
side structure this may not be a bad
idea at some point if I do do this it
would be right around this moment now at
least the knight cannot make use of this
square right away but is it necessary
how about we go for some type of mmm
mini minority attack is just one pawn
attacking these two but he is
unprotected and so you know a4 there is
no capture maybe my rook is brought to
life I'm trying to activate my rook by
doing this this seems unnecessary now
their queen has a responsibility you
shouldn't like that these are some moves
now all of a sudden I'm striking at d3
I'm throwing some punch of d3 but maybe
the idea is d4 I wouldn't mind seeing
that I get to undal some there still is
a weakness within my structure though
one of my C funds will be a target
1:11 okay it's not a happy move to make
throw the rope
in the corner and if I'm not mistaken I
think I can now win this pawn and I went
out to go Here I am on this three times
it's defended twice and it can okay
now why can I not just cash out they're
gonna have to show me
also I'm supporting the promotion square
which is nice that's a very good
benefits killer Bishop it's tucked away
nicely but it's doing great things let's
glue that bishop in there for starters I
also feel bit more comfortable playing
Knight e4 next now that I at least have
my and Bishop playing
um what to do here I could probably do
without my ceii phone at this point yeah
so I just want to make sure I get rid of
any block hater of this square and the
Queen would really be the last one to do
that there missed that I'm on the Queen
there but even on a queen exchange night
here there would be some problem because
the rook alone will not be enough to
stop this guy you know and we're just
pushing through Oh what am I talking
about there is no did I already did I
say something like there's Bishop takes
rook that's illegal you can't do that
I'm gonna play this one out and now
they're down on time okay well I got 12
as an bono which is a player who shows
up quite frequently in these uh created
tournaments yes 30 he's up there with
some fire
30:21 I am at 12 it may be a battle for
third try to sneak into third
let's see how about we play you form d6
okay
it's a former pawn duo okay they try and
some hippopotamus I like to get these
three pawns involved if I sense my
opponent going for a hippopotamus set up
where I can eventually play d5 I think I
want my bishop right here I want to keep
this Square open for my knight on
castles 91 a knight on d3 is really
really flexible I like having a knight
undie three if it's a locked structure
see pawns fixed and then white with this
slight space advantage whoa now that's
different
well sometime was clearly wasted here by
white two steps with the D pawn so do I
just start taking away and well let's
start with this one yeah now the e-file
has opened up so how comfortable can
black feel with their night here you
know he has to move before the bishop
moves or this kind of thing has to
happen probably with the night I don't
want to allow development with tempo
knight c6 Queen a form maybe even insist
on the follow up pins so I'm already
sensing that there's some kind of a
knockout
where is it let's start with this
capture opening up a bishop check yeah
so now actually that's checkmate how do
you like that
that's a double checkmate and just like
that a killer okay that was quick thirty
2117
okay second is doable I don't know about
first though he's really got a lot of
games in speedy that xanbot oh how about
we try d6
why not another invite here played this
opening not too long ago put the video
on YouTube with this d6 line
the invite to the queenless middle game
was just declined
so what's the plan
I like to hold off on the queenside
seems to be a bit more flexibility the
queenside um normally something I would
shy away from but maybe I can do c5 mm
now I'm gonna hold off on that let's try
4 well I'll go with this I was
considering Knight d7 but I think for
just that one moment the knight would
hop into f5 and I don't want to it seems
like a bishop that's not doing so much
but I think without my dark square
bishop around this pin could really be
painful so this damaged structure that
can result I'm not afraid of because my
C pawn would really negate the c3 Knight
and this is not a stable square for the
bishop so I think think rattling the
Bishop's position is good and so my pawn
kills their night that's kind of how I
view it and maybe I could look to put
some pressure on B to converge on the b2
square let's start with this and this is
a likely follow up because I definitely
want to have my rook seeing the game
I could insist on a dark square Bishop
exchange that might not be a bad idea
how about this smell pointing at f/2 and
Bishop back I have Queen f6 really
keying in on these dark squares ik as
you can see
this is a problem I think well the night
can't even move because there's this pin
ouch
that's a night now that's a rook
yeah they resigned a b3 move it's really
weakening now 20
all right um what's something else I
could try let's let's revisit before
um yeah let's see if black goes for this
capture I think that's the correct way
to do it
f6 huh
no that is different all right let's go
hey stream
and they just weak in their King
position I'm playing III to open the
bishop store open the bishops eyes and I
also want to strike at this guy right
away if this here I don't want to become
2 lakhs and I think taking that the
queen is fine notice there is not this
developing move so this is something
that you may mmm
one may shy away from because you're
bringing the Queen out too early but the
one piece that could highlight the Queen
coming out early would be a queen Knight
there shouldn't be too much of a bother
anyhow if Bishop played into e5 but now
I'm at least covering it um just Bishop
to here yeah I know
take with check they tried to do
something like that
all right let's castle be a little bit
careful of this kind of stuff I have
enough defense this is this is this is
an issue here I'll consider more
capturing on d5 once the knight has
committed once he's on d7 then taking
here in the recapture the night won't be
able to go here let's
um is this really being is this really a
threat if I go knight c6
I mean I am actually gonna do this I
change my mind
because I want I want the B 5 square I
want maybe a tempo here let's just keep
the structure I could probably allow
something like this it would still be
good
all right now where is the knockout I am
sensing that there is some kind of a
knockout right around the corner the
knight can still he cannot move because
of this move
let's jump up
I want to just go here and I just want
to keep his eyes open always clean side
castle they have a couple pieces oh this
is really really weakening so this is a
sore spot for sure this is a this is a
target
let's hit it right away
and guess they could try that my pieces
are slipping in very very fast
ah the night here is
the night right here is covering f6
Bishop is pinned clean exchange I'm
avoiding that um what I want to go
let's go all the way here now here this
is this pawn is pinned and now we have
knight discoveries against the Queen I
almost have all my pieces playing let's
jump in take out the dark square Bishop
maybe
I don't want to get into some kind of a
pin I know I just helped them develop
but they still can't castle and even if
they do there should be some great
drawback connected with that Knight
moves I could take here they have to do
something about this tension let's try
to undermine it a little bit that's my
that's what I'm guessing they'll do
now we get a rook on the sixth pointing
it a lot of stuff pairing to double I
just want a sack
all right now let me let me try
something else so don't have a lot of
time down to the wire Sam Botta slipped
up
let's try to double like this now they
could Castle now they cannot castle
Queen a4 they could have castled on that
last move I don't have any time now
that's blitz
down in time
they put up some resistance there
clearly I there may have been a knock
out there likely was a knock out but
obviously didn't spot it 34 25 24
two more games it's free more games
maybe I think the chess Prince just
finished who is perfect not the only
perfect one it's Bobby Fischer another
perfect one did I read that right we're
gonna find out
let's see Bobby Fischer throwing the
Budapest at me
I almost always play these positions
where I'm perfectly fine with giving the
pawn back
you know I don't mind like even right
now I keep thinking I'm missing tactics
am i right to think that maybe with the
kind of tournament I've had it's so far
so we're gonna have some mass exchanges
where I have maybe just a tiny advantage
maybe
if I go queenside with my king I'm
afraid of that a pond running wild
they'll probably stop that cold with b6
yepper
so now I'm thinking there's a absolutely
no advantage but I'm still going to try
for something this night could try to be
a bother
flight square wise I'm liking h3
definitely don't want to move that pond
and create a hole on f3
it may be that I need to challenge this
night soon or I could try to hop in here
I'll try to keep some life in the
position like a bishop versus night
maybe anchor upon here and have
something to bite out
so we'll play around some they're
offering a draw I definitely don't want
to draw and that doesn't mean that I'm
better here but I'll I think again I'm
the side that's still trying for
something maybe they're trying for a
push here hmm
well let's get back here they played a
five I didn't even realize that they did
that
that wrong to do that let's pull the
bishop back they keep offering draws but
you know I still don't want to draw
a little bit scary they have a few
pieces coordinated on this square could
definitely see an accident happening
soon
like right now we're gonna find out this
row can't go too far he has a
responsibility I'd like a little bit
more support here rook up Bishop e2
they're going to try to break it down
are they getting too much you know we'll
start with this in this Bishop e2 idea
let's see I think in the end I could
play g3 and have my rook defend
laterally there definitely a fast player
so I'm back about 20 seconds not cool
get some rook exchange rook d4 and they
get my knight right back here hmm also
there's Knight d5 can I get Knight d5 in
right now let's take here first and then
go here just so this pawn doesn't go
into pac-man mode on my bishop I think
this is a valuable tempo against the
rook think yeah cuz now where does he go
he has to do something awkward like this
yeah could take this pawn can I get away
with that we're gonna try it let's just
get that to kill that Bishop they have
round g2 g3 Bishop g4 mm-hmm
take care right let's give this check
that night is dangerous very dangerous
night
just wanna trade
a little bit get one rook off they help
me get one work off can I convert this
in time
hiking's a fighter
I want to undermine this night position
if possible
close to doing that have this square
cover the
motion ranked or the promotion square
let's give this check and then take give
another check oh I have this move
glad I spotted that I could take this
pawn with the rook check threatening
rook here they have to keep the rooks on
hard to stop mate now got the rook off
at least I will be able to get this
eight seconds is a lot less than seven
okay back to tournament 3730 28 seven
minutes and change okay fifty players
the guy in second is on fire the chest
prince is on my heels and trying to kick
me out of podium land okay
Oh can I get another pairing up as an
Votto is vers irking his current game
oh no that game was finished we have
zambano
alright so let's see what we can do
a BOGO Indian with a five and let's be
quick to offset
the light-square bishop
the a pond is gonna win the game maybe
I think I made them as this mistake
before
they could get this move in they should
have played e5 now I have an excellent
position well it's nub and compete in
the computers eyes it won't say better
but I like it or a lot watching out for
this square a dark square as a flight
square it's a light light square bishop
Queens off in the end it could be that
this pawn is a target this is super long
term but it factors in it is something
very real this is a super square for a
knight I could look to play on the
h-file this wasn't just some passing
move I'm looking for this that Knight
has to go elsewhere but I could look to
take them out doing this now let's get
this moving straight away I'm playing on
the h-file they're looking to take out
my knight and they will be successful
with that but I am ok with it the b-pawn
will be a target
this is a significant idea it is it was
poorly timed and I have to correct it
but you know the the idea is a strong is
a strong one so no way around it I mean
I'm going to support this pawn and soon
my rook will be at maximum strength
I want to make sure this position is
open let's hit my queen well let's let
my queen start hitting stuff Bishop here
I have all my pieces working and all of
whites pieces are really struggling do I
want to keep the Queen's on or not if
there is a challenge I don't think I
have anything there let's just get my
rook on b3 I might not be able to do
without an f5 break
I guess we'll start with this
and then this so can I make some magic
happen here
well actually Queen III is maybe a
threat yeah I have to do something about
that I could try for some transfer over
here but I don't know maybe even a king
walk
hmm should the rooks be off I want some
king security I'd like to play this
position where I keep this structure and
I have to come up with this fast okay
I'm gonna try to play within the
structure I think from a practical
standpoint this is not a well I think
that this is a good idea in Mike my
queen could try to probe and maybe at a
later stage I could look for f5 but I
think I want more pieces off whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
this is opening up one move here that is
now a game winner I'm getting the beep
on
rook has to go back we're gonna have the
cleans off but I'm gonna be up upon more
active rook and another one is close to
falling can I keep the Queen's on I
don't know down to a minute
a bullet time it is think I want my king
over on e7 now in this ending less than
fifty fifteen second advantage forty
let's see um yeah I'll grab another pawn
they can't go on the offensive so in the
end of rooks are gonna come off and
let's just maintain this strong point
okay
I thought maybe f5 was an idea with the
Queen here I have control over the dark
squares King a safe push here's the idea
and yeah this is tough now there should
not be any defense the Queen is actually
made it and now I could slip in with my
King and disrupt the bishops position by
force and I will be queening alright
they resigned and did I get that anytime
I did get it at a time
ooh the prince has withdrawn so maybe I
will hold on to third
less than a minute yeah I don't think
I'll be paired up
sambata will stay stay in first by a
point unless this guy is he in a game he
is in a game
yeah probably not going to finish unless
Y could pull off some Nate really fast
but I don't see that happening
it's my initial impression yeah I don't
see a mate happening 23 seconds on the
tournament clock not happening so this
one will now finish sand bottle will
hold on to first place easily 40 39 with
just a few seconds left 40 39 32 beating
out the chest prints only by tiebreaks
okay not a bad tournament a rocky start
with the first three games I would say
but ended up with a podium appearance
forty thirty nine thirty to thirty to
fifty players and also let's see all
five stage two three four I only played
a couple of games
okay and five already too
49 of you good games all